ブーバー知ってると思うんですけどマークドナルドはチーズバーガーって消費あっで
どんな釣りチーズが入ってるハンバーガーしかーしなチーズが入ってるんでしょこんな
感じで見てください
薄いんです薄いかつ結構実はが好きで来たの日ですけども
はぁ
多分抜いてもわからないですよね多分 trees ガーバーの地図抜いてもわから
ないと思うんですよ皆さんよく考えてくださいチーズって美味しいシュックリーミーな
んですけども判断がに挟まれて釣って影薄くないですかチャットも載ってるソニーも
関わってるしおいしい音1回も入ってるたちの頭れてるそんなたくさんの要素が含まれ
ている中でチーズが活躍できる合唱できるかというかなかったらそれはできないと思う
んですよね実際ちっ
何か食べてるみたいなチーズが各ないと思うんですよあんまりわかんないと思うんです
よちょっと馬鹿なら尚更の事っていうわけで今日の実験はチーズバーガーのチーズを
抜いてもわからないです
さっそくやっていこうよでは早速チーズを抜いていこうあの僕が結構あの租特チーズ
信者なんですよで僕ぐらいだからもちろんわかると思うんですけども普通の人だった束
わかんない気がするんですよね
いやでも僕でも若干わかんない気がしますではチーズを差別していこう
が濃いん
がっつりついてな
うわか普通についていながらちょっと頑張って取っていきましょう
me
ほぼないはずです
お肉代わり山意外と取れるな
ん
はいそれだけでチーズバーガーのチーズを取り除きますもうここねチーズ要素は残って
いません
あっはぁ拒絶しちゃったぞこちらが新在庫積み上げてチーズが入ってないチーズ会でも
結構な量のチーズが亡くなったと思うんでこれ結構興味深い実験だと思うんですよね
ブービーハンバーガーヌーチーずのスパどぅ r ということでみなさんにご理解あー
プロデューサーポルターゲット読んでいくを実験対し
pou dou dou
ん
んわーワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ワンワンワンワン
4ポンッ
ua
[音楽]
ん
はいもちろんトップ
靴はあーこれで石鹸って言ったっていう
それぞれ2ビックなってリョウくんだったからちょっと x バーガーっている場合
[音楽]
おます
えっ結局ちゃうないかいっ今結構ですね
だから新車したらめちゃくちゃばいい
[音楽]
ブーブー
voodoo
も5用温度はないん
根津らー
本
[音楽]
ん
10分
んチーズがないん
me
うううう
uh
4つ穴いたら
それに気付くパッポングループん
俺はなければをような妙な思いましたそれぞれ部屋を選びちゃんこれ長文や鳥居配って
くれる
トリフ持って奪い取るはパターンだ良いパーたんだぎー
られ一瞬でキャロっちゃったよ着の場所です夏だからああああ
場でねばっかだからなぁ気付かないと思った
パワー動画超水気を今日のハグぐらいっていけな
3部で4分だよ
#ロサはエンディングドワーフなんか持っていきましょうよえっあの花の女王なあああ
あいいい感じでどういったティロスレっ
おっ
持った
ポンポンポンポンポンポンポンポンポンポン
本北海ポッっ4んっ
ef んですよパーカー
バッハバー
ああああああ
ああああああああ
バッハ
ああああああわああああああ
ああああああああ
ああああああ
うわあああああ
ヴァッハウ
[音楽]